Pavan has jests with you in his
introductory lecture and the tea purport
very much emphasizes that making
decisions about trade-offs about the
present versus the future are inherently
ethical and yet they have this economic
component in them in my job today is to
hopefully maybe try to tease trying to
tease some sense out of that in a simple
way
now the discount rate is a key parameter
in the economics of ecosystems and
biodiversity it's a key parameter of
really in environmental economics and in
cost-benefit analysis more generally
maybe we should say that discount rates
are key parameters because there's a
plurality of discounting we're going to
see that what this cannot rate one
applies depends upon one's one's moral
orientation and it depends on the
specifics of the policy or the project
that's under evaluation but still
discounting is very fundamental and I
want to start out with the observation
that when we talk about discounting
we're talking about cash flow analysis
we're using economics language economics
jargon and we're using concepts from
finance and so we're using a particular
kind of narrative framing which is to
think that Natural Resources the
ecosystems and biodiversity are also
that they should be managed as forms of
capital of natural capital now what is a
capital stock I mean a capital stock is
a is a stock that generates a flow of
services over time and we can invest in
capital stocks and increase the benefits
we get in the future we can liquidate
capital in stocks and which maybe we get
a short-run benefit from but that
reduces future benefits and future
services and it's so a capital stock
then as a store of wealth that provides
a flow of services over time and II
Tillet Aryan is going to say well we
should attach equal weight to the
well-being of present person
some future persons and if we take that
argument that moral premise we can
construct an argument that says that we
should be using actually a positive
monetary discount rate but a monetary
discount rate that's much lower than 7%
you know and the reason that we should
that we should the reason that we might
discount future monetary values if we're
utilitarians is if we believe that
future generations will be better off
than we are so at the margin an extra
unit of income is less valuable to them
than it would be to us the worst and
suffering people in 2011 so that's one
argument
Pinchot is is represented as a
utilitarian but Pinchot's argument was
that natural resources are the joint
property of present and future
generations and that the present
generation has a right to obtain its
share of the benefits but also to
sustain the resource and pass the
capital stock and tacked on to future
generations and that's a framing that
says that the present generation has no
right to impose uncompensated harms on
those that come after us but that's an
invasion of their rights it's an
invasion of their human rights possibly
and you know invading people's rights I
mean we can argue about how much I would
need to compensate you if I inflict a
harm on you but your right to be
protected from harm isn't grounded in a
cost-benefit calculus actually it's
rights and rights Trump economic
considerations in in legal systems
generally that really we're talking
about Thomas Jefferson who wrote that
the earth belongs and yousuf Rock to the
living which is a beautiful short piece
of text that's from the letter to James
Madison about the public debt Jefferson
wanted there to be constitutional
provisions against the accumulation of
debt so the well that that that was what
he was writing about and he was using
this this analogy about the earth
belonging and usufruct to the living and
what that means
Natural Resources land forest ecosystem
services biodiversity or our common
joint collective property my property
it's not Provence property it's not your
property it's our property and the US in
this framing according to Jefferson
isn't just people who are living today
it's members of future generations the
use of high discount rates is
appropriate for risky investments that
provide gains and losses that accrue to
the investor personally you know so the
market rates of return represent
personal values or personal preferences
about risk and about the timing of
getting payouts for example you know but
conserving ecosystems conserving
biodiversity it's a precautionary
investment you know it's secure future
it's a means of securing future human
flourishing it's a way of reducing
potentially catastrophic irreversible
risks that frankly we don't understand
at all well when we're undertaking from
a finance perspective when we're
undertaking actions or investments that
reduce rather than enhance risks then we
use low discount rates in fact we might
use a discount rate that's even lower
than the risk-free the risk free
discount rate which is already starting
out at 1%
you